I could not be more excited to have all
of you on board our first ever
[Music]
I'll do it
[Music]
you must be the one and only Dracula
you'll be the Shula it could be B
there's just something about an accent
that makes a man sound so intelligent
[Music]
everybody just please watch the hair
[Music]
you know actually I was thinking you and
Johnny should spend some time together
what do you call it again a date night
come on Johnny we are arriving at our
final destination I give you the
legendary lost city of Atlantis
place you've gotta be
I believe the singing
Aaron's waiting over here for you
take you out then you need a monster
vacation gonna lie
I've taken care of everything in the
likely event we experienced a sudden
drop in cabin pressure all right thanks
that would be never
I'm gonna go check on you know hey
there's singles
why are we on a blade we can fly you
know I'm so stressed out lately it's
time for you to relax
now isn't that better any meat plant so
we get that bill oh you know the usual
you got to take the kids to soccer
are you overworked and stressed out
then you need a monster vacation this
time around we are actually all leaving
the hotel and going on vacation welcome
aboard
I've taken care of everything
Clady that would be Lily I don't think
he'll be fine crumb layer again anytime
soon
that's all you said all right thanks the
monsters are setting sail on an epic
cruise ship
welcome to the Bermuda truck where
you'll embark on a monster but of course
it's a cruise as only Hotel Transylvania
Camp Hotel Transylvania 3 has a great
voice cast a newbie they could be theirs
thinking about an accent that makes a
man sound so intelligent could be day
everyone you love is back and more
Corsica Adam Sandler or Dracula Selena
Gomez and dresser
[Music]
okay dad thank you forgot the guys back
David stay oh you hit me right in the
heavy James Andy Samberg Molly Shannon
there's some new additions as well if
Kathryn Hahn Jim Gaffigan who do you
mean Chris Parnell that's right Joe
Jonas Chrissy Teigen oh my gosh I'm like
so excited everyone's just up for a new
adventure and Denis is definitely
growing up really fast tingles is
Dennis's new puppy yeah you want tinkles
he's the size of an elephant so you can
imagine what kind of shenanigans a giant
puppy might cause wait till you see the
itinerary everything is catered
specifically to monsters welcome so
there are some familiar elements like a
daycare for cute take my kids purpose
can you get them back at the end of the
day no well that's better than nothing
they take advantage of it sounds like
everything we can do there are lots of
fun destinations from the triangle what
I think it's so great about Hotel
Transylvania is these scary monsters are
made lovable I think the main reason
people love Hotel Transylvania movies is
because the characters are fun and
relatable and even though they're scary
and they're monsters you kind of get
where they're coming from
okay pennis we don't want to alarm the
human thank you young man
it's a really awesome concept than it's
done in this fresh is very very funny
way there is something about that woman
I don't trust must have been garlic in
the guacamole isn't that deadly for you
was that you so it's even more epic and
more fun I think in my humble opinion in
the first two movies must am
you never really know what to expect
you were right great-grandfather van
Helsing monsters are disgusting they
have no idea what's about to happen to
family I can't wait to go see this movie
I just cannot wait gonna be so much fun
I love the feeling of making people
laugh because there's not a better
feeling your world say goodbye
[Music]
Denis who is this hi Bob what can I help
you with Lord of Darkness I'm looking
for a date the date is Friday July 13th
no no I want to meet someone
understood you want to eat dim sum don't
you get it I want to go on a date I'm
lonely I understand you want Bologna
though many eyes though few eyes not
into Pentacles dad baby you're stressed
out from working too hard you need a
vacation from running everyone else's
vacation and I know just how to fix it
maybe are we going come on what to do
you could go scuba diving try some
exotic food
[Music]
or just enjoy the views thank you maybe
you'll find your own fireworks on the
cruise it's not The Love Boat Frank you
must be the one and only Dracula
hey do BD Shula a coup BB there's
something about an accent that makes a
man sound so intelligent you were right
great-grandfather van Helsing monsters
are disgusting they have no idea what's
about to happen to them
all going according to plan
[Music]
there is something about that woman I
don't trust the food here is to die for
must have been garlic in the guacamole
that's deadly for you hey was that you
oh no Blondie's gonna puke flow for a
century the hotel has been his life but
next summer
vacation
oh you can eat buffet whatever spot yeah
so impressive it's like a hotel on the
water
[Music]
[Music]